i was a drug dealer a big drug dealer so
anything i ever did i grew in it wow um
it's not to glorify it in any way it's
just to show you that god will give you
a spirit of entrepreneurship but it's
it's up to you to decide on what side
you're gonna bring it out
[Music]
what's up everybody
i'm pastor corey brooks and i'm still
here in this tent can you believe it 100
days from november 20 to february 28th
on this block that's called oh block o
named after a young man named od perry
who was shot and killed and the gangs
picked up his name
and called it o block we decided we're
gonna keep the o but it's gonna be
called opportunity block why because
we're creating opportunities that's why
i'm here in this tent to bring awareness
to the violence but most of all to build
a community center to give opportunities
to people who need it so desperately
we're trying to change a generation and
today i am so grateful to have on this
rooftop revelation
tina jackson and tina is a wonderful
sister who is a ceo of her own
restaurant and has a remarkable story
off time we hear about the brothers in
our neighborhood who have had trials and
difficulties and gone to prison but
today i want you to hear from tina
jackson i want you to hear her story and
all about what she's doing right now to
help change the lives of not just our
family but other young people who have
been in the situation that she's in so
welcome tina thank you
tina real quick we're going to jump in
because we don't have a lot of time
tell people you know
about your 17-year incarceration how did
that happen okay it's over like three
bits though okay okay so actually i was
a gang member
the gangster disciples for years
and i was a drug dealer a big drug
dealer so anything i ever did i grew in
it wow um
it's not to glorify it in any way
it's just to show you that god will give
you a spirit of entrepreneurship but
it's it's up to you to decide on what
side you're going to bring it out on
right absolutely i know you said you
used it uh being a drug dealer we hear
about a lot of guys being drug dealers
but not too often do we hear about
uh systems but i wanted people to know
in chicago there are some sisters who
have gone that direction and done some
things so you were 17 years
incarceration um drug dealing i know you
had about 10 people working for you
making money and what happened you end
up getting caught and doing a lot of
time and during my time of incarceration
like i said it's your mindset so if you
don't do anything when you go in you'll
come out the same age 10 years later
yeah so it was up to me to make sure i
put something in my mind on a daily
basis so i obtained my associates degree
while i was in there i got all kind of
certificates from culinary for custodial
i taught those that were less fortunate
to learn uh how to read how to write and
that was a wonderful thing so i just
kept my mind working and got came home
and obtained my bachelor's so let me get
this right so while you were in prison
you decided i'm not going to stay the
same i'm going to grow even in this
environment so you start going to school
got your associates um you start helping
other people uh i know i know because
i've talked to you that you were in the
choir you were
the dance ministry that you had to start
started building a relationship with god
in prison
and all of that do you think made a
difference of course i know when you got
out you said you got your bachelor's
degree i did and i became a stout member
of grace apostolic faith church where
actually i'm the minister alliance
leader so awesome yeah i do that i love
that so what happened when you got out
you got out of jail you got this
associate degree you got your your
bachelor's degree what what what did you
do
i i went to work i started working at
firestone and i love i love that job but
a guy came in and saw how savvy i was
with selling parts and different things
like that on cars and he offered me a
job at autozone pen just a little more
money
so i left right and then i met this
young lady who i called my grandma my
grandbaby named stephanie and she showed
me a building that a gentleman had and
he wanted to a restaurant
and when during my bachelor degree i had
to write a business plan and my business
plan was called wings greens and things
and my daughter daisha said
mama you can do this
so i looked at the plan i started
reading it got in my spirit and i i
started that's awesome
and you know what and that's you're the
type of you're a model of the type of
sister we're trying to help
uh
a sister who may have went the wrong way
but now wants to get back on track
and one of the reasons why we're
building this center is so that we can
have an entrepreneurial school
so we can teach people how to be
business owners because that's so
important in our neighborhood as relates
to the violence and a lot of people
don't understand
why that's important but it really is
because
people need to have
financial foundations they need to have
things that they can rely on
and build and
inspire their children to maybe even
pass on
and legacy and so it's so important so i
want to thank you for being a model for
what we're trying to do and your
restaurant the food is so good
and for anybody who's ever in chicago
uh tell them where to go
come to wings greens and things
6767 south south chicago we're
definitely making a difference on the
southeast side you can look us up on
facebook you can google us and you can
look us up on instagram it's a
tremendous story
a sister who did 17 years in prison
decided in prison i'm going to make life
better i'm going to educate myself got
out of prison
start
developing her skills
utilizing her mind
doing things the right way starting a
business and now that business is
thriving
and i got one thing to ask you is your
life more peaceful now than when you
were making that money as a drug dealer
a piece that surpasses all understanding
amen bless you thank you tina love you
much all right
listen it's been a blessing thank you
for tuning in to our rooftop revelations
and i want to thank fox for giving me
the opportunity to continually share the
experiences in chicago as we try to
eliminate the violence from our lives
but most of all we got to build this
community center so i want to say thank
you thank you thank you
you